he better be able to get it up they made
fun of that last guy who was on here
that couldn't get it up they ate him
alive and I was like well thanks for the
boat accomplish yeah that's that's nice
to hear yeah it's all right I still
knocked it out
all right Mason yo what's happened
welcome back hey how's it going welcome
back you were one of the most
surprisingly interesting people I've
interviewed yeah I thought uh thank you
for saying that I thought I was going to
be hated because of my job and I was
actually
um really surprised and welcomed by all
the positive comments I got from your
audience I think your personality is so
likable oh thank you and you're so open
and just honest about your crazy
lifestyle just be yourself man and you
had some great stories they have a the
saying that like uh don't be afraid to
be your true self because you never know
who who you might meet or something like
that so you be yourself you're going to
attract people that you're honestly
gonna supposed to be in your life
something like that before before we get
into this what there was one question
that everyone
wished I had asked you last time or wish
you you would clarify there was one type
of party that you
did
Health Care thing or something like
hospice parties oh yeah hospice party
yeah so hospice tell me what a hospice
party is so um so my you know back in my
earlier 20s when I first started dancing
in Las Vegas or stripping rather for Sin
City strippers I uh uh we get house
calls a lot because you get a lot of
locals you know and I think I was maybe
24 25 years old at the time and uh we
get a call to do a hospice party and uh
this old lady she's dying and they're
having a a
party at the house you know her
husband's there her her son and
daughters are there her grandkids are
there it's like what you would go to
like a a big party you know they were
having a party for the mom she was going
to be passing away soon and I pulled up
in the driveway at the house and I
remember that was one of the ones where
I just I I didn't know what to expect
you know taking deep breaths in like all
right let's go in here and let's try to
do this thing and uh when I walked in
the room and hit me immediately because
even in the living room at their own
house she was literally in one of those
kind of hospital beds they had a nurse
on standby there but it was funny she
had a big grin on her face when I walked
in they even gave her a stack of dollar
bills to have in her her lap and I guess
she had she had mentioned I guess she
had never had a stripper and wanted to
get a stripper so you know this is where
I come in and uh I I did my best to have
a good time I remember dancing it was
just kind of weird because I was just
kind of dancing for like and she's
laying there in the bed and
um she's got pictures obviously all
around of her grandkids and kids and
stuff like fat and the kids are out in
the back and that's time it's just kind
of the handful of the adults that are
there and you know I danced for and even
though like I'd like to think that I've
made her forget about the reality of her
circumstances just for a few minutes and
it seemed like good energy there was
still this over gloomy feeling and it
was just uh I don't know man it was sad
I cried after that party and I think
about some things sometimes and it makes
me extremely sad that you know I I I saw
my own Humanity in that party that was
the first party that I had done or it
wasn't all sex crazed you know women or
young people out to just get partying on
drugs you know doing the cocaine off
your dick and all that stuff this was
this girl was dying and uh when I got
done dancing for they had a bunch of
food and barbecue and some picnic tables
in the backyard I had a couple beers
with the husband we exchanged numbers I
ended up talking how old was she
it's been so so years ago I want to say
she was she wasn't incredibly old I want
to say mid mid 70s maybe early 80s it
wasn't you know she wasn't incredibly
old I think maybe she'd she'd come to
cancer or something I I don't know
exactly the disease that she had had but
um I ended up staying in touch with her
husband a little bit after because
ironically enough I live on the south
side of Vegas and that house was on the
south side so I would drive by their
house all the time and think about this
girl and I'd send the husband text every
once in a while and uh about six weeks
later after I did the party you know I
found out she died and uh I would just
like to think for a minute you know that
I gave her just a moment of happiness in
that time I was able to make one of her
um where they call it uh risque
um taboo fantasies come to life and it
even though it was heartwarming I just
remember being really hit by reality
after that party it's like because it
seems like no matter who we are we all
mourn death the same and we all
Celebrate Life the same and it's just I
don't know man that that will always
that that party's always going to stick
with me
um you have more than your share of
crazy stories of debauchery and yeah
that's just typical but does this work
ever get to you
as far can you elaborate get you down
get you depressed make you feel sad
about
sometimes uh
it can
I don't want to say depressed but like
when you do parties like that you feel
down afterwards like uh just to kind of
go in more detail I've done a hospital
Wing parties where I've gone into actual
hospital rooms I'm telling you what the
nurses don't like that but I did a
hospital party where the girl wanted me
to come in uh like the Top Gun I did the
officer and gentleman with the white
suit and I came into highway to the
danger zone and she wasn't leaving that
hospital and uh her grandson was there
it was just me the grandson and her in
this hospital room I know half the
nurses were kind of poking their head in
laughing there was a couple of them that
seemed like they were really upset that
I was there they insisted that she
needed her rest and she told them that
she'd rest when she was dead I remember
that and she had this great spirit and
and you know talk about getting down I
remember leaving that that hospital
um you know room going back out to my
car thinking that this girl is not going
to be able to do that she's not leaving
that [ __ ] room and I didn't stay in
touch with them afterwards but I'm
assuming that was years ago too I'm
assuming she's passed on onto the other
side
as far as like
doing normal parties and getting
depressed like I said in the previous
interview you know I come from very
humble beginnings you know like really
humble beginnings like my you know my
childhood was good but it was still full
of of [ __ ] and negativity that
everybody has you know uh uh so when I
go into these things it's like I don't
know man I
it just it uplifts me most of the time
it really really does I like because to
me and again I I kind of I think went
into detail a little bit last time that
there's a difference between a female
and what male strippers have to do I see
myself as more as an Entertainer I'm
coming in and giving like an
entertainment performance like uh I'm a
huge fan of wrestling I grew up on WWE
and I feel like I've I've put on this
Persona this Mason Knox and I get to
come in in these elaborate outfits and
dance to these my entrance song and put
you know happiness on people
um the only time it gets kind of really
depressing sometimes is like again I
mentioned it before when like
the girl that they're hiring me for a
lot of times it's a surprise but usually
the girls that are hiring for me for
someone they know their friend really
well and
they know if they want a stripper or not
and I've been in situations where as
soon as I've walked in I've had girls
start crying saying I don't want to I'm
burying my husband I love my husband
I've had Girls run and lock themselves
in the bathroom I've had Girls run and
lock themselves in the other room and
like anybody else it's kind of weird to
walk into a hired situation you
immediately feel unwanted it's like oh
okay well that was a little bit weird
you know so again I'd like to to you
know
I can't think of any really down
experiences I mean I mean some of some
of the interviews I've done lately
especially with the The Fetish world
have shown me how how dark parts of our
society are do you have any stories of
yeah kind of I never got
I mean I know fetish you can be such a
broad term
um so without sugar coating anything
I've told this story a couple times you
know they're cuckolding or cucking is
what they call it is when a husband or a
boyfriend likes to watch their wife or
girlfriend get [ __ ] basically uh
there's no way sugar coating that that
seems really popular these days and 95
to 99 of my parties with those kind of
couples are really happy like and again
I'm not advocating to be a swinger but
just in my line of business swingers
seem like they're the most happiest
people in the world like the Hat they
had the most open and honest
relationships and again the wife's
usually expecting it you know when I go
up into the room they're already usually
in lingerie sometimes they'll have
candles lit and they got the music
already going for you you know what
you're getting into
um I did a party a few years back at
Caesar's Palace
um and in my protocol for these these
couple calls as I always meet them or at
least the husband downstairs first first
and foremost I like to sit down at the
bar have a beer with them build some
kind of energy and you know feel their
energy and build some kind of trust and
I could tell right away this guy he was
whacked out I mean I know he whacked out
he could he'd done a few you know I
could say he was hopped up on Red Bulls
but we know how to be lying he
definitely you know had a had a little
nose candy for sure and he was like he
was talking naughty you know people
think I talk fast this guy was [ __ ]
talking fast and he was like oh yeah man
so glad you're here yeah I want you to
[ __ ] my wife good yeah you're gonna [ __ ]
her good yeah and I was like well I was
like yeah we'll get to that man you know
I'm having a vodka tonic trying to get
to know you he's trying to rush me to
the room so again the Energy felt a
little off but it didn't feel
intimidating enough for me to turn it
down so we get up to the room and the
wife is sitting there on the bed kind of
shy and which is pretty normal at first
because let's face it the the fantasy of
things can be a whole lot [ __ ]
different than the [ __ ] reality and
uh
I get there and I start this off like a
normal strip show I think I had my cop
uniform on something like that I did
copper Cowboy I I don't exactly remember
um put the music on started stripping
and it's when I got down to all my pants
Velcro so I'd rip the pants off to give
her a strip show and I got down to my
underwear
um that's when it started the energy
really started turning this guy was like
he was literally sitting from like me to
here on the edge of the bed and the
wife's like in front of me so he's he's
in it and he's going yeah baby pull his
dick out I pull his dick out and I was
like all right in those situations I
always let the girl take control and I
remember going hey if you want to you
know I mean I'm just here I'm
entertainment you know I'm here for your
fantasy basically and I could tell she's
a little reluctant like again the energy
just didn't feel like all my other
parties in the past it felt like when it
came to this kind of taboo and uh she
pulls my dick out and you know she
starts kind of stroking my dick a little
bit and that's when he starts going yeah
baby stroke is Dick yeah put that
[ __ ] dick in it in your mouth you
know and I'm going like again in hey you
know if you want to you know no if you
want to go ahead and she starts kind of
sucking my dick a little bit and giving
me a hand job but she's not I can just
tell she's she's just not into it and
mind you I I'm a hired performer and
I've never met these people I'm in a
hotel room I'm I'm comfortable [ __ ] you
know I'm I'm expecting to maintain a
hard on this thing's and then he says
something again that I've brought up
before that'll it'll stick in my mind
forever his exact words were yeah she go
he goes if you want me to give you a
baby and you want that money that you
asked me for you better suck his dick
clean now and I was dude that like I get
horrible I get those chills just
thinking about that that was looking at
this guy and I put my dick back in my
pants I told I told his wife or fiancee
whoever it was we're not doing this you
know I politely finished my bachatonic
with a little conversation and I excuse
myself out of the room
um
I'm not judgmental on people I think
people that know me know that I'm really
open with a ton of Lifestyles but I
don't think
he he wanted the dick in his mouth I
could tell that guy had some gay stuff
and I think he was trying to live
vicariously through through
um his wife or fiancee I don't know what
they were married or not but he
definitely was really into it he was all
about my dick and I was just like I was
thinking this whole time like this is
this guy wants to be sucking my dick and
you know he doesn't really want his wife
to but this is as close as he can get to
it probably without being shamed because
you know some people think it's wrong to
be gay when you know someone should tell
that guy it's okay to be gay one day
but that that when you talk about dark
and taboo that that that that when
people ask me like what's the kind of
darkest thing that that story is always
the first one that pops in my head
and where where is your career gone
since uh last time I saw it it's been a
little over a year right yeah I think
what are we in October and we saw each
other maybe I think August of last year
so uh
um you gave me covid
yeah or you gave me coveted no you gave
me did I give you covered I had it like
three days after you okay yeah I didn't
even know I had it as jumpy as I was in
that interview but yeah and uh I thought
it was I thought it was immune to it and
then oh well maybe you are now because
we've both gotten it and now our bodies
our bodies know that the how that works
I guess but I mean luckily we came out
of it okay
um sorry about that obviously I had no
idea um I probably went to the gym one
day and it affected a bunch of people
not even knowing I had it I just thought
I was really hungover and I woke up one
morning when I this morning I called you
I was I was like
it's like
I can't and I went right to my liquor
cabinet at the time and just started
grabbing my strongest Bourbons I
couldn't smell a damn thing I was like
ah [ __ ] I got the covered that's when I
called you how long did it last for you
seven days if that
yeah that was when it was really serious
this was like last a year that was when
it was like a big deal it was a big deal
yeah so you had to quarantine for like
14 days and all that yeah I did all yeah
as soon as I lost my smell I just stayed
at home and stuff like that uh um I was
taking care of my grandpa and we got him
out of the house uh Mike uh I mentioned
before my adopted father my godfather
Steve he owns Delights Hot Springs
Resort in tacopa California which is
like a really small town in California
so we got we we tried to get him out
there and then uh uh but it was too late
you know he got covered oh he did yeah
Joe's dead
from covet yeah wow yeah my grandpa's
dead oh [ __ ] I'm sorry about that yeah I
know it's all good I just uh a lot of uh
a lot of people ask me about him on the
uh on the interview and he he passed
away he passed away at 94 years old 94.
he lived a long life and uh
um you know we tried we we we begged him
to get the vaccine when it first
happened because this was you know this
has been months after Cove would have
been out this wasn't when it just
happened it'd been going on for a minute
he just refused to do it he didn't want
the medicine he thought it was a hoax
thought it was [ __ ] and we did the
best that we could with what we had and
as soon as I found out I had no smell we
tried to get him out of the house as
quick as we could but it just you know
it got him and it killed him it's I
missed my grandpa man yeah so yeah
sorry
sorry he's a he was a good dude I
I didn't I didn't
I really like to take care of him
like the last time we did that interview
I I remember making him coffee and
breakfast and stuff that morning I just
I don't get to do that anymore and you
know when I when I do bachelorette
parties at night he would always be up
late at night he would always be up he
was up all hours and when I got done I
usually get done with work about one or
two in the morning and I'd hit the
McDonald's drive through for him every
night because he always liked to get two
cheeseburgers in a milkshake and uh uh
for the first couple weeks coming home I
remember I went to McDonald's to grabbed
myself a cheeseburger and I I wasn't
grabbing him one
oh [ __ ] I didn't know that was still
down there yeah I missed my grandpa Joe
I'm sorry about that it's okay man
so where is your career gone since since
then since last year so same thing I'm
still doing I'm still doing the the
husband wife thing still knocking out
bachelorette party after bachelorette
party
um I have though in the last year since
we've we've uh We've uh
I had the last interview in the last
year I started doing adult films more so
I got into working for a few companies
and I got my only fans page going and I
started working with other entertainers
and I've I've worked for bigger
companies like a plug talk I've worked
for like gruby and trans Angels like
I've always openly been into trans so I
I've done a lot of trans transporn
so it's been great I don't know if it's
something I'm going to keep doing but
it's something I really wanted to try
out it's not as fulfilling as my
entertaining job how does a life that
revolves around
sex work
get to get to a young man
how does it I I remember I was a kid I
always wanted to be a porn star you did
yes I remember when I was a
when I was real young uh you know back
in the I'm going back in the VHS days we
used to still we found my friends dad's
porno collection his parents porno
collection they had a big trunk and we
would still two or three porns at a time
and you could hook up your remember the
big cam quarters that had to you could
hook those up to VCRs and you could it
was like pirating that was the first you
know you could steal the tape and I
would uh I would copy the pornos and I
had a video rental service you could
rent porns for me for five bucks a night
when I was in Middle School uh and that
was you know and I just always thought
when I would look at porn magazines when
I was a kid and when I'd see it you
would see the the kind of same handful
of guys and I just thought wow like
that's the life like that'd be so cool
to be that guy and you're gonna bang all
the hot chicks and they pay you to do it
like it was such an alluring
uh fantasy as a kid and just getting in
the stripping and stuff I think I
mentioned before it's just people just
get a lot more comfortable with asking
you to do more things and then you meet
more people in the adult industry as you
go on so you know I figured I'd try it
out and see how I like it you know uh
and here you are yeah here I am is there
no dark reality to that
fantasy not that I've
the only thing I can think of dark I
mean I haven't really experienced
anything like dark on set or anything
like that but it's a very and just I'm
only speaking from my experiences it
seems like there's definitely and I get
it it's work but to me even being an
adult Entertainer and hooking up with
girls over the years
um are still always a connection you
know you're still talking now important
there's there's no connection I feel
like I have two of a soft Soul maybe for
porn I'm gonna try it out for a little
bit longer see how it goes but I don't I
don't think it's something I'm going to
be doing for much much longer it's the
again the fantasy of that to me
is a lot was a lot better than the
reality for me anyway again I'm not
knocking sex workers I'm not knocking
porn stars I mean get your money have
fun but I don't know if it's going to be
for me it's not for everybody yes I've
gotten older too no I'm you know I'm
looking for a Mrs Knox so uh have you
been in love how old are you I just so I
just turned last September I just turned
38. 38. have you been in love before
yeah I've done the love thing a couple
times twice it would be hard with this
lifestyle yes and that's another reason
why I was thinking about maybe stepping
back from it because if you do want to
get with someone serious you either have
to step out of the lifestyle completely
and then there's always the the uh
um then you always have to bring up I'm
an honest guy I'm an open [ __ ] book
so any girl I kind of date now I let him
know hey I you know if you search my
name I've done adult movies and I've
worked with trans performers and I
remember I was dating this one girl for
a long time on and off I'm not gonna say
her name but she was a great person
still is I know I love the [ __ ] out of
her we're always going to have love for
each other but she saw our first
interview and she goes I didn't know a
lot of these things about you and I
remember I brought up back in Indiana
when I'd walked into the gay bar that
first time it was just too much too
quick and when I told the stories about
me working with trans she was like I
kind of have the same feeling kind of
about you now I don't know and she's
kind of pushed off for me since so
you're gonna get dark I may have I don't
want to say ruined but I I've definitely
put a damper on any kind of relationship
we could have maybe had in the future by
doing adult films for sure with her
particularly I don't I'm not going to
say that's going to be with every girl I
meet but you know I really liked her man
we've known each other 10 11 years
there's certain careers sex worker
careers that have more of a stigma to
them than others yes exactly and porn's
definitely one of them like girls can
always get over you being kind of a
stripper nobody even even a prostitute
she does what she does for three years
and then she quits and like it's like it
never happened at least there's no
there's no proof of it oh yeah but with
me there's gonna be proof of it as long
as there's the internet you know it's
always going to be out there again I'm
not ashamed of anything I've ever done I
I've enjoyed every performer I've worked
with uh I just bringing them out there
gruby is a trans company and they are
one of the coolest companies I work for
like I've a lot of the nicest people
I've met or behind the cameras in porn
they're just such sweethearts and
open-minded people I just don't know if
it's for me like I said I want to give a
little bit longer but you got to listen
to your gut so we'll see what happens I
like I I brought up on my previous
interview I'm actually an author now so
because of your audience I really got
the fire up under my ass and I wrote
that book they're asking me about so
um again just like I'm not trying to
plug but if you want to get the book you
can get it now it's at masonnox.com and
it's the Mason Knox the true story of a
Las Vegas adult Entertainer so in every
book comes with a free audible and I did
the audible myself which by the way
[ __ ] sucked man I when you read in
your head
you mispronounced words you know what
you meant so you just keep going when
you're trying to keep tone and your your
personality while pronouncing every word
I am a stripper you know I'm not
necessarily the Highly Educated uh the
highest educated man reading your story
is different than telling it yes and
then you become dyslexic after reading
for like four or five hours I thought
they were starting to come together but
yeah I did two seven hour days in the
studio that were hell and when I got
done I didn't know when you use your
brain that much you feel like you worked
out in the gym I was exhausted from
those [ __ ] audibles yeah that's why I
like this format because
whatever we did today you can't
duplicate tomorrow no or next week it's
like it's just sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't that's why I only
work I only use one out of five that I
do and I just uh I just I just click
with your show too I just I I just I'm
just being me like I just I've told my
audience that any podcast I go on I'm
just openly and honestly me like what
you see is what you get I can't take
back the things I've done
um there's a saying that can go by you
can you you can't subtract and divide
you can only add multiply and take that
for what for for what you will
yeah I think that ability to be open and
honest and not have skeletons in your
closet
is not only what goes over well on my
channel but it also goes
well just me in life again like I I joke
around that you know I've heard of this
magical guy named Mike I am magic
[ __ ] Mason and people laugh at me but
it's like I've done this for 16 years I
used to you know I used to walk to work
to Taco Bell man you know I I was my mom
had kicked me out of the house like
17 18 years old I was a senior in high
school had my own place and you know my
dad my biological father passed away
when I was like seven or eight years old
and you know my mom and I always bed at
heads and when she finally got the first
chance to give me the boot she did and
that made life hard you know I I I I as
I've gotten older because I'm a man now
uh not having a support system when
you're running around as a kid it can
make life a lot harder what was your
relationship like with your mom right
now and what was it like it was okay but
it was always
I don't know man it just wasn't that
great you know it just we were always
butting heads she never I remember my
aunt got onto her one day because she
would never say I love you back to me so
um I'm no psychologist but maybe I
became a stripper to get love
from women that I never got from my
mother I mean there may be a little bit
of that in there again I I'm an open
book I I'm no psychologist but who knows
uh and she's just she was hard on me man
like uh when I was walking to work to
Taco Bell my brother Brent was nice
enough to let me stay like I had lost my
house obviously in high school because
I'm a high schooler I don't know how to
manage my money too well I wasn't able
to pay rent anymore so I got the boot
from the house I was renting and my
brother let me rent one of the spare
bedrooms in his house and he said the
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to get a job and it was cold in
Indiana and he dropped me off and and
people in Greenfield know this there's a
road called State Road 9 where all the
restaurants are on he dropped me off in
snow and said do not call me till you
have a [ __ ] job and just kick me out
of his car and so I was like [ __ ] I
gotta get a job quick and I walked into
Taco Bell and got a job uh it was about
from his house to Taco Bell was about a
mile there and a mile back I know I
sound like my grandpa we walked a mile
at the school a pill and a mile downhill
or whatever words I walked to work and
it was very humiliating sometimes
because I was 18 or 19 by this time and
I was working with a lot of high
schoolers and a lot of my friends that
were going to universities and doing
college would come in there for lunch
and there I am in a [ __ ] Taco Bell
you know form again I'm not trying to
dis fast food workers but
it didn't feel good to work there man
and I finally gotten like I'd saved up
like 600 700 bucks and finally was able
to buy this car and uh you know my mom
at the time was still living in her
[ __ ]
those two-story four-bedroom house on an
acre of land in Indiana and a nice ass
neighborhood that my my body my
biological dad built by the way and I'd
go try to go visit her sometimes and you
know something that'll
stick in my head forever man is I pull
up in the driveway one day and uh she
knew I was working at Taco Bell and I
just got the car man I was like so happy
I had [ __ ] I had a car that I I paid
for I haven't changed the alternator out
and put the belt in myself I was like it
felt good and she looks up and died at
me with a [ __ ] Coors light in her
hand and goes you're going to work
shitty [ __ ] jobs and drive pieces
[ __ ] cars the rest of your [ __ ] life
and dude I just Audrey killed me 19.
I mean I don't think I was 20 years old
yet man I wasn't even old enough to
drink and it's like
[ __ ] man you rest really [ __ ] hate me
and uh guess who's not driving piece of
[ __ ] cars anymore I own two BMWs I have
a house on the Las Vegas Strip and I and
I and and say what you will about
stripping that that entertainment
company I work for is one of the best
entertainment companies to work for and
I'm you know I I've come a long way
because I went from Taco Bell to working
at this paper goods company called
bunzel Bunzel's a warehouse just your
typical warehouse work
what really got me to Vegas was I going
to work one day bundle's been around
forever and they're celebrating this
guy's retirement I'm 21 at this point
and uh they were celebrating his 35
years at buttonsville because I remember
I seen him on the cake walking in the
break room and they had the little
stupid balloons you know they see those
little stupid office piece of pizza
parties [ __ ] uh that guy has a tick
tock about it it's [ __ ] hilarious but
uh
I walked in and I was like I was 21 at
the time and I was like this guy has
been at this company 14 years longer
than I've been alive
holy [ __ ] I was like
I had a breakdown I remember crying
again calling my brother on the phone
and just telling this can't be me this
can't be me this can't be me and you
know at that point I'd started kind of
you know I think I talked about it
before in your last interview I was
stripping at PT's on Saturday nights
during that time and so and that job
made me feel really good like all my
problems when I was like I think you
know again like I'm such a wrestling fan
I grew up on Hulk Hogan Stone Cold Steve
Austin The Heartbreak Kid Shawn Michaels
I was there when he super kicked Marty
Genetti you know he broke up the Rockers
you know my one of my greatest memories
in my biological dad was you know
he took me to WrestleMania 8. you know I
was there when Bret Hart beat Rowdy
Roddy Piper for the Intercontinental
Championship belt you know you know I
watched you know the ultimate warrior
and come and save his friend Hulk Hogan
When papa Sean go and Sid Justice were
beating him up and
Macho Man Randy Savage defended Queen
Elizabeth's honor against the Nature Boy
Ric Flair
and I just I've held on to wrestling so
much and
I just just wrestlers talk about how
when they're in the ring or even hear
band people talk about the play music
that when they're on that stage you're
on that platform you come through that
curtain that curtain opens up you know
for me when I walk into that hotel suite
ready to [ __ ] go is you know magic
mace and all those problems go away
everyone [ __ ] loves you they're all
hot I mean again people think I make
[ __ ] up usually it's very attractive
women I'm dancing for are throwing
hundreds of dollars at you hundreds
cheering you on when I rip my pants off
it's like a pop that you would get when
like you're you're when if like your
favorite basketball team hit the winning
shot at the last second every time I do
the velcro what oh holy [ __ ] it makes
you feel so good and it's like I don't
want that to stop man and every wrestler
will tell you when they have their last
match you know and I got more years
behind me than I do ahead of me now you
know I'm that little 22 year old little
Mason anymore I'm I'm I've grown into
the man I'm 38. I got maybe 10 years
left if I want you know and I uh
I do this because I love it I love
entertaining Mark I do it's it's great
you know if I was a little bit bigger
and maybe had a little bit more training
I would have went out yet a younger age
for wrestling I tried wrestling school
once and let me tell you man that that
mat hurts you know but I I one of these
days Mason's gonna shut the door to his
last party and it's gonna suck and I
hope I'm in a better state of mind but I
think there definitely is something that
stems from the rejection of my childhood
maybe I was going to say do you think
having a parent like your mom
motivates you gives you a drive that
maybe somebody who had a better
childhood doesn't have yes I really it
may be an unhealthy drive but it's still
still a drive like uh you know my
godfather has been a blessing in my life
let me tell you man I'll bring up his
name his name's Steve again
you know he has four sons of his own and
he just he said when he took me and I
was just I was just a lost puppy is what
he said and I owe him the world man he's
taught me a lot about the world he's
given me structure he's you know he says
you know when when you feel like your
life's messed up and you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] up or or things aren't going your
way go to your [ __ ] bathroom and look
at that guy in the mirror and that's the
guy to blame and going back to the drive
thing he always told me you gotta want
it you've got to [ __ ] want it you got
to get mad at it and you gotta [ __ ]
want it you gotta want it get mad at it
and [ __ ] want it and dude that stuck
with me I didn't tell me that like when
that was like at the age when I was just
kind of getting kicked out and they they
took me in that was like right at the
beginning we me and him sat down here in
the carpet store in Indiana at the time
he sat down and talked to me and it was
just like you gotta [ __ ] want it I
believe pain is the
the most the purest most high octane
fuel there is yeah man because you got
to get mad at it and you it it again it
may be unhealthy but if you can Channel
your your anger into
achievement yeah and again life is not
perfect man and I I'm not I'm going to
put you at center of attention but I'm
sure you've had trauma I'm sure that
that you know that the top World actors
all the way up to you know like Brad
Pitt you know Ryan Reynolds I'm sure
they've all had stuff in their childhood
that everyone does it's like one saying
that really helps me get through life
these days and I I it life is full of
beauty life is full of suffering you
cannot control what happens to you you
can only control how you react and man
when you really take a deep breath and
let that sink in it's you know people
are like how can you not you know I
remember your last interview like
there's no way this guy's as happy
happiness is not once happiness is being
happy for what you have I used to walk
to work the Taco Bell I got told I was
going to work shitty jobs and drive
shitty cars by my mom my whole life you
know I I used to work at a paper
goodness warehouse at buns on I I took
that drive of not wanting that and this
stripping was the way in when I did that
first nudes of popping dude I felt like
a super star man I got paid a couple
thousand dollars that weekend girls were
lining up to [ __ ] [ __ ] me suck me I
had trophies my last my last nudes of
pop and I did was a few years back but
you know Dennis Rodman gave me my trophy
and hung out with me for a minute he was
Dennis Rodman man the [ __ ] worm was
calling me Mr Vegas I watched him on TV
when I was a little kid I was a little
kid watched him and Michael Jordan and
Scottie Pippen and the Bulls back in
their Heyday this guy's handing me a
trophy now and calling me Mr [ __ ]
Vegas you know there's nothing more
unattractive than a grown man bitching
Mark and I've learned that from a young
age you know [ __ ] you Embrace Solutions
not excuses and again I have my down
days but I call people have anxiety they
say or they have you know dark thoughts
that's called The Fear wolf everyone's
got it I call it the fear wolf and you
can't let that thing out of his cage
that fear wolf you let out of its cage
it's going to start prying it all your
insecurities all your darknesses all
your childhood trauma and you can't let
it do it life is short man it's full of
beauty and full of suffering you can't
control what happened to you but you can
control how you react to it 100 percent
Mason yo another amazing talk man you
think so absolutely sometimes I feel
like I ramble on no you're great and
people say I talk fast again I don't
mean to break the third wall but before
we end this interview I'd just like to
say a few things to your audience
because I don't have time to reply to
all these messages that are the comments
I just don't
um and I don't want to I'm not trying to
be a dick but I don't get sucked into
that that much I'll reply to a few but
yes in the last interview I meant to say
optimistic and not pessimistic you made
a mistake made a mistake and no I have a
high energy
um I have a heart condition called wpw
and sometimes it'll make my heart pump
really fast and I'm just an energetic
guy I don't do meth I'm not yacked out I
know a lot of the comments are like this
guy definitely did a hit of meth before
your show it's like no I just I have
this natural highness about me you know
I just there are a lot of people that
are like that there are they're totally
clear I do uh this morning like I'm
energetic I at my hotel this morning
before I came down your studio by the
way which is fabulous if I could marry
anybody had a chance to see Mark's
Studio here I'll be moving next year but
uh um uh two cups of coffee man I'm
[ __ ] I'm good I mean I can't even
handle Red Bulls really so but again I
just want to say thank you for giving me
a chance to tell my story and uh just
thank you to your audience for being so
welcoming to me because I really thought
that when I did your show the first time
I was a little iffy because I was like
man these people are gonna [ __ ] hate
me no I mean they're a huge hit they set
it up being really nice so I just always
like to uh you know leave on a high note
like I said like the the last uh I'll
say it again guys I like this and on
this life is full of beauty life is full
of suffering you cannot control what
happens to you you can only control how
you react and once you let go of your
ego
a lot of your problems will go away
peace and love beautiful thank you Mason